تصاعد المخاوف من المسيرات ومباتت تشكله
من تهديدات على الامن القومي للدول جعل
الكثير من الشركات تفكر في تقديم حلول
دفاعيه تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي
[تصفيق]
عمليه التحليل الاستخباراتيه المدعومه
بالذكاء الاصطناعي هي احد المجالات التي
تختص بها شركه مارس الدوليه للتكنولوجيا
الامنيه للتعرف اكثر على احدث المنظومات
الدفاعيه التي تقدمها الشركه معنا مدير
شركه مارس الدوليه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
السيده اندي فوربس في من العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض اولا مصر اندي اهلا بك معنا في
عسكري تيريا في ظل تنام التهديدات التي
تشكلها الطائرات المسيره ما هي اهم
الاليات التي يجب ان يتمتع بها نظام
الدفاع الفعال
نعتقد اننا دخلنا مرحله حروب الاله
بمواجهه الاله في ظل ان تهديدات المسيرات
حاليا تتمثل في كونها مسيرات ذاتيه التحكم
لذلك نرى اننا لمواجهه هذا التهديد الذاتي
يجب ان نجعل انظمتنا ذاتيه بدورها ونجعل
الالات تتعلم اتخاذ القرارات بسرعه كبيره
كي لا يضطر ان اشغلها لاتخاذ القرار بنفسه
لاننا عاده ما نعاني من الوقت الكبير
المستغرق لاتخاذ القرار النهائي حيث ان
سرعه القرار بالغه الاهميه لمضاهات سرعه
قرار الاله المسيره والتهديدات المصاحبه
لذلك
مصر عندي يعني الى اي مدى تقيم كفاءه
المنظومات الدفاعيه التي تقدمها شركه مارس
ضد المنظومات المسيره بشكل عام
نستخدم ما يسمى عمليه تصنيف الاجسام
الذكيه الهجينه وهي خليط من الذكاء
الاصطناعي وارقام الاحداثيات التقليديه
مما يعطينا القدره على التمييز بين اكثر
من 1000 جسم في السماء خلال ساعه ومن ثم
نحدده هويه المسيره كي لا نطلق تحذيرات
كاذبه لكن علينا كما قلت ضمان ان قدرات
الاله على اتخاذ القرار سريعه بما يكفي
لوقف المسيره التي تواجهها نحن في هذا
المجال في المملكه منذ نحو خمس سنوات
وانظمتنا كانت تكسب المعرفه خلال هذا
الوقت وبالتالي اصبحنا نتمتع بخمس سنوات
من التدريب في الذكاء الاصطناعي لمواجهه
اخطار المسيرات كما ان انظمتنا تتمتع
بقدرتها على التشغيل باللمس في نظام مركزي
متاح للمشغل دون الحاجه للوحه مفاتيح او
فاره او ذراع تشغيل وبالتالي من يستطيع
استخدام الهاتف الذكي او الجهاز اللوحي
قادر على استخدام انظمتنا
مصر اندي فيما يتعلق بمنظومات الاستخبارات
والمراقبه التي تقدمونها الى اي مدى
تعتمدون على الذكاء الاصطناعي في هذه
المنظومات
اتسبب
كما قلنا في الذكاء الاصطناعي مهم جدا
لهذه القدرات لاننا بحاجه لتلك القدره على
التشغيل الذاتي لدينا مجموعه عديده من
البيانات حول الانظمه التي كنا بصدد
دراستها لرصد التهديدات ولتتمكن من تحديد
اي هدف ان كان مسيره او طائره او طائرا او
من طادا وهويه اي تهديد نرصده في السماء
اذ لا نريد ان نربك المشغل بكميات مهوله
من البيانات حول اخطار ليست بتهديدات
حقيقيه والذكاء الاصطناعي منحونات تلك
القدره لبناء النظام الذاتي المناسب
لاستخدام
فيما يتعلق بالذكاء الاصطناعي مستر اندي
يعني الكثير من الصناعات الدفاعيه باتت
تعتمد عليه الان لكن كيف تتوقعون مستقبل
الاعتماد على الذكاء الاصطناعي وهل لديكم
مخاوف من تنامي قدرات الذكاء الاصطناعي او
تنامي الاعتماد على الذكاء الاصطناعي او
حتى خروجه عن السيطره في يوم من الايام
نحن نرى ان الذكاء الاصطناعي مهم جدا
لتسريع عمليه اتخاذ القرار كما اننا نعلم
ان هناك اشخاصا في هذا النظام وهذا العنصر
البشري موجود في اي عمليه لكن ان فكرنا في
كم التهديدات التي على مشغل النظام
التعامل معها ان لم يكن لديه دعم من
الذكاء الاصطناعي فانه سيخضع لضغط شديد من
المعلومات والمسؤوليات التي تقع على كاهله
لكن هناك دائما مكان لعنصر بشري في هذه
العمليه كي يتمكن من اتخاذ القرار النهائي
حول ما يتوجب فعله عند مواجهه هذا الخطر
لان السرعه التي يجب اتخاذ القرار فيها
ستكون صعبه على اي شخص يشغل النظام لذلك
هذا العنصر البشري موجود في تسلسل عمليه
اتخاذ القرار
وقعتم عقد مع السعوديه لبيع المنظومه راد
ما هي القيمه المضافه التي تشكلها هذه
المنظومه بالنسبه للمملكه
هي عباره عن قدرات تم تطويرها عن انظمتنا
السابقه حيث ان النظام بحد ذاته قادر على
ان يجمع مجموعه من الرادارات وكاميرات
الرصد تربط بين الانظمه ولديها قدره على
ان تعطينا ابعادا افتراضيه لموقعي ما بعرض
400 متر تقريبا وعمق 62 مترا ونصف ما
يعطينا صوره تغطي 25 مترا مربعا لمنطقه ما
وهذه القدره غذيناها بالذكاء الاصطناعي
ستمكننا من متابعه اي تهديدات تدخل ضمن
هذه الابعاد وباستخدام القدرات الذاتيه لا
يضطر المشغل لمتابعه مسح الموقع بعينه
المجرده بل النظام يقوم بالمسح نيابه عنه
كما عملنا على تصميم هذه القدرات بحيث يتم
تشغيلها على الطاقه الكهربائيه ومن دونها
ما يعني تغذيه النظام بالكهربائي او
باستخدام لواقض الطاقه الشمسيه ونحن نرى
ان هذا ذو اهميه للمملكه ان اردنا التشغيل
في مناطق نائيه وكذلك يتم الربط مع انظمه
اخرى تمكن المسؤول عن التشغيل ان يوفر
محيطا مؤمنا بالكامل باي موقع كان
مستر شركه مارس الدوليه بمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط شكرا على وجودك معنا